ce geste n'est désormais plus
obligatoire pour emprunter les
transports en commun au québec et cela
en ravi plus d'un longtemps qu'on fait
les autres places non enlever ya
longtemps
bien sentiment partagé du côté de québec
maintenant on va
entrer dans l'autobus et pas les masques
en tout cas j'aime beaucoup il reste
toutefois des sceptiques face à ce
nouvel assouplissement dans le métro je
devais y ait trop de monde je vais quand
même aux heures de pointe le garder dans
le wagon je considère que nous n'avons
pas encore totalement
fini cette cette phase que nous
traversons depuis deux ans donc je
préfère rentrer en garder mon masque un
petit peu le port du masque est
obligatoire au québec depuis bientôt
deux ans mais pour certains c'était déjà
chose du passé ça faisait quelques jours
que je le mettais feu doi moi je porte
déjà pu le masque depuis longtemps le
mois dernier il a été levée pour les
lieux publics comme les restaurants les
salles de spectacle et les centres
sportifs populationnelle c'était la
dernière cette année dernière et on est
très contents de ce parce que la
situation le permet le masque demeure
toutefois obligatoire pour les centres
hospitaliers et 6h et celle des les clsc
et les cliniques médicales
j'aurais pu avoir lieu plus tôt là cette
fin du masque obligatoire dans les
transports en commun ça fait longtemps
qu'on est passé à une autre phase de la
pandémie dans laquelle les mesures
collectives de prévention ont de moins
en moins de sens et il convient
maintenant
de faire des actions plus ciblées auprès
des populations les plus vulnérables
la santé publique fédérale prévient que
ce n'est pas une raison pour baisser la
garde on serait étroitement les
souligner comme la beac à t5 et ce qu'on
voit actuellement c'est que lala
pourcentage de ddd
dépistage et aux états qui sont b à 4 et
5 a
augmenté il n'écarte pas une
recrudescence des cas cet été ici daniel
quatre jours radio canada montréal